good afternoon i'm deborah adam simmons
executive editor for history and culture
at national geographic
i am thrilled that we will have a
conversation this afternoon with
historian martha jones and writer
michelle duster about the role of
african-american women
in the suffrage movement while we know
that
um august 2020 is the 100th anniversary
of women's suffrage we also know
that suffrage wasn't guaranteed for all
women even
after the vote happened and so we will
hear today from
martha and michelle about the work that
they've been doing
to chronicle the experiences of black
women
so martha uh you are a professor
at um john hopkins university feel free
to um
tell the audience more about what you do
but i'd also like you to set the stage
for us of the environment
for women black and white women both
before the civil war afterwards as it
relates to suffrage
well um thank you so much deborah um and
thanks to national geographic um
thanks also to uh the women of impact
group for
um hosting me it's an honor to be here
especially uh
especially with michelle duster so thank
you so much
um you've asked a huge question um and
as you know i've just finished a book
um called vanguard that looks at 200
years of
african-american women's politics with a
focus
on the quest for voting rights
um it's a story that for american women
um certainly has one beginning in the
early decades of the 19th century as
women across the united states the
relatively new united states are
beginning to ask
questions about um their status their
standing
their um their vexed positions
in american politics um the early 19th
century is an
era where american political leaders
don't apologize for
using both what today we call racism
and what today we'd call sexism as
arbiters of political rights so the
first part of the story really is about
the
raising of american women's
consciousness
some do that within anti-slavery
societies
others do that within church
organizations still
others in literary societies um but
there
is a kind of um political awakening for
american women
um that will um if you will
really take hold in the years after the
american civil war
when the u.s constitution is being
revised
when millions of former slaves are being
incorporated
into the nation as citizens
it is a revolution that we call
reconstruction
and american women are very much a part
of that
now very pointedly asking
what kinds of new rights they should
enjoy
um in that period it is also a vexed
time when old allies out of the
anti-slavery movement in particular
have different ideas about who should be
next when it comes to voting rights
um african-american men educated which
is
sort of code for uh white women or um
or should there be universal suffrage um
is the question of the 1860s and this
will lead to
a sort of splintering of american women
and their allies
that will take us into the 20th century
the founding of
two women suffrage associations and by
the end of the
century the founding of the national
association of colored women
which for me is as is the equivalent of
african-american women's
suffrage associations a body that is
organized around anti-lynching but also
around women's suffrage and many other
civil rights concerns that african
americans bring to the table
thank you so much for that
we know that um uh francis allen
uh watkins harper said that uh we're all
bound up together
and that for black women um
uh their their rights as as african
americans and their rights as
women could not be disentangled uh
michelle duster
you are the great granddaughter of ida b
wells and she really was the epitome
of fighting for both those causes can
you talk about
um talk about her work
oh wow um well as martha said thank you
so much for having
me um this is really an honor to
participate on the national geographic
and women of impact and obviously to
have a conversation with martha jones um
like that's also kind of a big question
my great-grandmother was really
um focused on overall i think she was
focused on civil rights and
um equality so
voting fit into that the right gaining
the right to vote fit into
what her overarching um
goal was and so she's most well known
for the um journalism work that she did
regarding
um exposing the the actual horrors
and reality of lynching
but i think just basically basically
based on her own life experiences
she realized that
laws had to be changed and policies had
to be implemented
in order for um african americans in
general and african american women in
specific to actually um
have greater chance of equality and so
she
looked at voting as a tool
to um have influence over the
people who have imp input
and influence into who created the lungs
martha can you talk about the um tension
between black women and white women
at this time and really how that has
played out
sort of historically but in particular
can you talk about the
sort of splinter and and why it occurred
you addressed some of that
um in the intro that you gave us but i
think there's a
limited understanding of just how
complicated those relationships were
so african-american women organize
by way of a political philosophy as i
suggested that in
decries both racism and sexism um
but along the road to the 19th amendment
they encounter
um suffragists white suffragists
frankly too many of whom continue to
condone um used strategically
and otherwise um are complicit
with anti-black racism within um
the various facets of the suffrage
movement this means that
the suffrage associations that we most
frequently associate with the road to
the 19th amendment
are never really hospitable or
comfortable
um places for african-american women to
organize
um and it's important to say black women
don't spend all their time trying to if
you will ingratiate themselves into
those associations and instead
build their own political movement by
way of organizations
like the naacp like the national
association of colored women
and more when we talk about the suffrage
movement we really in my view have to
talk about the suffrage movements
because african-american women over time
will create their
own
michelle can you um can you talk to us a
little bit about the
um the 1913 either of you really the
1913
march and why um the suffrage march
was significant
i mean i can give my perspective and i'm
sure
martha can add more details but um as a
great granddaughter of ida b wallace who
who participated in the march
um in 1913 the state of
illinois which is where my
great-grandmother was living
um gave women partial suffrage
which which was um they had the right to
vote for presidential
in presidential elections and municipal
elections
for whatever reason they weren't able to
vote in statewide elections
um and so around that
same time um my great-grandmother writes
in her book about how she had been
involved in
suffrage organizations in the state of
illinois
which led up to that 1913 um
partial suffrage but the the
organizations that she was
affiliated with were predominantly white
and so after the next the um
the partial suffrage was was passed in
illinois she decided to form an
all-black
suffrage organization and she talks
about how
black women and that this is what she
said um
that black women were sort of
not super involved in the suffrage um
efforts
and i guess were a little bit cynical
about the idea
of you know how this could actually lead
to empowerment
and so um she went to
the march in washington the suffrage
march
as the first thing that she did as
representing the alpha suffrage club
because it was about a month or so from
the time she formed it until the march
happened
and so she went as far as i know she was
the only african-american woman
who went with the illinois delegation
which was all white
but she was considered a peer in
illinois
and they had planned to march together
but then the black women were asked not
just her but all black women were asked
to march in the back of the parade
and she had a real problem with that
since she had been working with white
women all along in illinois
so she ultimately refused and then and
then managed to
march with the illinois delegation
anyway and that's just
such an important metaphor for what that
schism
uh was like uh um
martha can you talk to us a little bit
about the sort of protest
movement of the um suffrage era
uh you know there were the parades are
also where the silent sentinels who
um you know were abused during their
their protest work talk about that for
members of this
women of impact group who may not know
that much about them
sure um we're focused here on largely
on the work led by alice paul who
goes on to lead the national women's
party in the road to the 19th amendment
but paul had been if you will had come
of age
in britain um and among suffrage
activists there she was um
she was a traitor in a confrontational
um and even radical style of politics
um that included the kind of political
theater of the 1913 march
5 000 plus women upstaging the
president's
inaugural parade which is scheduled for
the next day it's
really remarkable um and then as you
allude to uh deborah in 1917 and 18
hours paul
will with her comrades picket the white
house
um looking to pressure shame
embarrass woodrow wilson and his
administration
into supporting a federal amendment for
women's suffrage
that will lead to civil disobedience
as we sometimes say that will lead to
white women suffragists being
arrested and detained as political
prisoners
albeit briefly so alice paul
um works if you will up front
while other white suffragists like
carrie chapman cat
are working behind the scenes working
the back rooms of washington working the
dinner parties of washington
um looking also to change the
president's mind on this question
and they are as we know ultimately
successful
this two-pronged approach
that will lead to wilson's endorsement
of a federal amendment
and finally what becomes the 19th
amendment coming out of congress
now can you talk about some of the
pressure that wilson was under
it's my understanding that even some of
his own family members the women in his
own family
sort of pushed him to reconsider some
earlier positions
i mean the the pressures are tremendous
by this period and they are only
exacerbated by the entry of the united
states into the first world war
um the war effort um you would think
um would lead to a kind of consolidation
or unification of the nation around
politics
but alice paul is not only intent on
continuing
to keep the pressure on the president
while other suffragists are prepared to
stand back
during the war she is prepared
in us to go ahead and even liken
wilson and his refusal to support
the vote for women she will liken that
to
fascism abroad and um
and really um upped the political stakes
for the president
if i could say one more thing that um
because i want to keep african-american
women in this conversation it's
important to note that
yes there are black women who ally
themselves
with alice paul at least episodically
we've heard the important example of ida
b wells
um also mary church terrell who as best
we know is the only african-american
woman to
participate in those pickets in
washington in front of the white house
there are some black women who join with
paul
but many more black women are facing
far too many burdens politically in this
moment
anti-lynching is still a critical
question
african-americans how on earth will they
get to the polls
ever if they continue to be
ground down by the scourge of
intimidation and by lynchings violence
um so black women are continuing the
work of anti-lynching
by the time we get to the 19-teens
there's an effort afoot in congress to
repeal the 15th amendment
which in 1870 had been the
constitutional amendment that prohibited
states from using race
well that becomes part of the political
um game that surrounds the 19th
amendment so african-american women
yes are concerned about this campaign
um and many of them supported of it but
are also
having to confront a panoply of
political issues
all of which go to the heart and soul of
them
their own lives and of their communities
and we know that many of those issues
persist today
because we're gonna in a few moments
shift to
talking about where we are now i just
want the participants in the
conversation if you have questions
uh please um put them forward and the
organizers of the panel will see that
they get to us and we can pose those
questions to
our uh panelists um so much
of of what has happened historically
is now bubbling up as we are on the
um on the one hand on the heels of
waiting to
see who a vice presidential
uh running mate might be you know might
it be a
a woman who um this would really
paint a very different picture than that
picture in the u.s a hundred years ago
particularly if it's a black woman
uh but the country is also you know
living through a pandemic and
important for this conversation
significant rollbacks to the
voting rights act of 1965 so
we know that um 1920 didn't really
guarantee anyone rights
1965 shored up those rights and then in
2013
uh some of those rights were taken away
uh martha can you give us a sense of of
what happened in 2013 and why we're
feeling the
impact of that today 2013 in the u.s
supreme court case of shelby versus
holder
declares that critical provisions what
are called the pre-clearance provisions
of the
uh voting rats act of 1965 were
unconstitutional these were requirements
that led those states who had
historically
disenfranchised voters to pre-clear
to get federal approval before imposing
restrictions
or restraints or rules on voting rights
that requirement was gutted by the u.s
supreme court and so today we
see a resurgence i would say of state
level laws and policies
not unlike those that were in place in
1920 that kept black women from the
polls
a hundred years ago today we have state
level laws
voter id requirements purging of voter
rolls
the shuttering of polling places which
have returned us
to a new era of voter suppression
you're right to point out of course that
is further exacerbated
not only for black women but for all
americans um
when our state leaders appear to be
fumbling on the question of how to get
us
safely and securely to the polls in
november
and so michelle you have been uh
referred to
as a generational activist i don't know
if you
would necessarily describe yourself in
that way but can you talk about some of
the work that you're doing
to draw attention to voting issues and
others
well um i mean what i'm focusing on
mostly because there's there's so many
issues
um to focus on and i think
just for sanity's sake you know it's
kind of good to focus on a few
and so what i've really been working on
is creating public history projects
that recognize
the contributions of my goal is to
recognize the contributions of
african-american women
overall um but since i can't do
everything at one time i've
decided to start with my
great-grandmother
um you know not just because i'm related
to her but because she wasn't
you know a really um pivotal figure in
our country's history
and this started with um
there was a housing community in chicago
that was named after her called ib wells
homes
which were a very significant um
housing community located on the south
side of chicago
not far from where she actually lived
and it
um stood in chicago for over 60 years so
it was a very
um well-known location and it kept her
name in the public space
and it started to be torn down in 2002
and so i felt strongly that she was a
woman not a building
and so even if the buildings are gone
she the woman still needs to be
recognized
so i've been working on getting a
monument created
on the land where the homes once stood
i was involved in getting a major street
renamed in chicago
after her called iw wells drive um
i've gotten a couple of historical
markers and now i'm working with some
women to um get some
some recognition for um illinois
suffragist
of which she was one of them but on
their first project that we're working
on is to have a mural created
that will recognize many of the suffrage
leaders for
from our state and i ultimately would
love to have a
monument created for illinois suffragist
so my
um focus has been to create a little bit
more equity in public spaces because
the representation of african american
women
in monumental and statue form
as well as all other you know street
names building name school names
all the other ways you can honor people
we are greatly
misunderrepresented um are
underrepresented
um only probably less than three percent
um are you know focused on african
american women
almost some almost one percent when it
comes to national monuments and african
americans make up 13
of our populations of black women make
up six percent
so at the very least we could have
five percent um so
just to give really short um example in
chicago there are about 50 statues
and of life of real people and
the first one to a black woman was
created in 2018
to wendell and bronx and so
and i'm creating a monument which is not
a statue and it'll be the first in
chicago
um to honor a black woman and then in
new york city for example there are 200
statues
and only five represent women
period and i think that well there's an
effort to
create a couple um i think it's called
she built the
nyc effort to create
i think three statues to black women so
here we are in 2020
and we're bill we're still at the first
i think it matters uh representation
matters
i was going to ask a whole series of
questions about um
about monuments and about learning um
particularly since there were so few
examples for you to draw from
where did you get your inspiration and
what was the process like both getting a
street named as well as
a monument approved installed
well the monument is going to be
installed
um this fall if everything goes right
um that we started we meaning i'm on a
committee
um we started working together in 2008
so this has been much more of a marathon
than i ever anticipated
i i literally never imagined it would
take 12 years
um so the process has been um
[Music]
this this project i think is unique
because it is going to be
on the land where something else was um
and and there's a there was a
displacement
that took place of an entire community
um
and that's different than i think some
other you know
projects that might just be in a park or
something but you're dealing with the
annihilation of an entire community
that um was vibrant um and some people
want to think about it in their whatever
way they want to but the bottom line is
people lost their homes
and their community and so we had to
work with the community
um there were there were a lot of
emotions
um that are probably unique to some
other situations
and so um
this process has been working with
a group of people who are involved in
sort of
quote revitalizing the community
community or redeveloping it
um but also some community leaders as
well as politicians
so there are a lot of players um
involved in this
process um and so in that way i really
do think it's unique compared to some
other
projects that i've heard about um
do you think it could be a model for
replacement of so many
of these other monuments that are coming
down around the country
um i think
i think that there just needs to be um
stronger conversation
about who
and what we celebrate
in our country um and
i personally think that eliminating
everything that we might find offensive
um
could potentially
you know lead to amnesia of what our
country has been
i think we nec we need to recognize that
our country
has for the past hundred and something
years
um celebrated you know
um mass murderers racist
um slave holders slave um
traitors i mean so if we
erase all of that then there could be
you know i'll just say 100 years from
now then there could be a denial
that this ever happened so i think we
need to be reminded of that but i think
that we need to um have equal or more
representation
of people who fought for um equality and
justice
um so i don't think
erasing the bad history gets rid of it
right
we need to acknowledge this happen too
okay we um have a question from our
facebook group for
um for i guess for both of you black
suffragists consider voting and
obligation
in my view black suffragists consider
voting first and foremost
a sign of full citizenship
there's no question that there's a
symbolic value to voting
and on the other hand there is the um
the very practical
sense that voting is a tactic right it's
one
tactic by which black americans men and
women
might be able to win political power
and resources um and both things are
true
right the symbolic value of the vote but
also the very pragmatic
um insight which is that the way in
which political power
in the united states is meted out in
part is
every of every year on election day
okay another question um did barry
church tyrell or w.e.b du bois or others
compare the national women's party's own
hypocrisy
about voting rights to the hypocrisy of
which they accuse president wilson
so the questioner is essentially saying
are are you know
were the white women's organizations
guilty of the same thing they accuse
wilson of
i can try michelle i don't know well
yeah
i mean because you know ida wells and
mary church terrell are
interesting um figures in this story
because um they do not abandon their
relationships
with white suffragists holy even as they
are strained even as they are tried
by racism and so in this way
um yes there are moments when
you know outright denunciation of um
policies and views
um that are part of the suffrage
movement are in order
um but what's remarkable i think about
some of this black suffragists is that
racism is the order of the day they know
that
um and their question is how to use
every strategy available to them um to
get to goal
which includes the goal of the full
enfranchisement of black
women and men um and
in some days that means showing up at a
parade where you're not welcome
um it means um attending
a suffrage association meeting where
many people don't welcome you
and i think both ida wells and
mary church terrell really characterize
that kind of very nuanced tough nuanced
leadership
and nothing less is demanded of black
women in the era of jim crow
nothing less and can both of you speak
to the importance of black women's
organizations
in um and creating a support system
and a network to do the work that they
were engaged in
well i mean
i think yeah i mean black women had been
involved in
um club movements for several decades
um and i mean the the bottom line is
that they they did not have the right to
vote
um and so their
sense of empowerment or or their the
power that they did have
came from um collective organizing
within these clubs
um and so and a lot of the clubs
um were organized and i mean i think
this is true even today
um we're sort of we're organized within
the church structure
um and and still today in 2020 that's
where a lot of black women
have a sense of empowerment
um so if you are working as a collective
group
you know and then as a group you go to
some uh power structure some power
figure and say
you know we as a community we as an
organized group are making this demand a
request
there is a sense of empowerment even if
you don't have the vote
i mean we can see that today even with
to say some of the young people who
are too young to vote right now but
they're still making their voices heard
and they're still
making on some kind of an impact because
they have
a collective voice um one of the things
i wanted to say
to kind of add to what martha said about
uh black women
and and dealing with white suffragists
or
um is that i say
my great-grandmother and i'm sure other
women did not look at all white women as
one you know one thing i mean they were
just as diverse as
as we are and i mean you know as i
mentioned my great grandmother worked
with white women in illinois um in
suffrage
organizations so there were white allies
as well as there were white women who
were opposed to or you know
um believed in segregation and so it
wasn't that cut and
dry um a very rigid
color line and i think that's important
you know in all fairness to recognize as
well
okay um martha can you talk about the
book that you have just written
thank you for that um vanguard uh
how black women broke barriers won the
vote and insisted on equality for all
looks at 200 years of african-american
women's
political thought and political activism
the road to the 19th amendment and then
beyond that
to the voting rights act of 1965 and
comes right up to our own time
i wrote the book in part because i
wanted people to understand
where figures like kamala harris val
demings
stacey abrams and others the political
tradition out of which
black women come in the united states
they these are not women who landed from
someplace else in 2020
um at all in fact that they themselves
will tell you
that they reach back to a shirley
chisholm or a barbara jordan
in the 1970s or in ida wells or a
married church tarot at the beginning of
the 20th century
or back even to the 19th century a
sojourner truth or harriet tubman
so i wanted to write a history that
helped us
appreciate the long tradition of black
women's politics
the long struggle for black women for
not only voting rights but for
little political power so that we could
better
read the political landscape in our own
time
um so thank you it'll be out on
september 8th but you can pre-order so
please do
i'll point out that you did write a
story um
that published on national geographic
last week
and there is a link to the book in that
story so
we encourage people to read the story
and click on the link
i'd also like to mention the story that
we did
in the august issue of national
geographic magazine
uh michelle duster is unfeatured
in the story and martha jones is quoted
in the story
before we get off this call i might
actually be able to um
to call that up but i don't want to do
anything that
will destabilize an already shaky
wi-fi connection so we will
keep going you mentioned um the names of
several of the black women who
appear to be contenders to
be the vice presidential running mate of
joe biden what do you think the
significance is
um of this moment where you have you
know
several women of color being in a
conversation several black women in
particular being in a conversation
um about being the vice president of the
united
states you know do you think that's a
sign of progress
or um given the environment that we're
in
is it political theater what do you make
of this moment
you know one if it was one
black woman i might say it was window
dressing or political theater
but there are at least six formidable
distinct black women um
all of whom in their own right
um are not only viable but forceful
contenders for the vice presidential
slot
and of the democratic party that is not
everything we've talked about voter
suppression and the ways in which black
women are going to be kept from the
polls
this year but it is also true at least
in my view
that what we are seeing is the fruits of
the struggles that black women have
waged for political power
particularly since 1965 and the passage
of the voting rights act but even
beyond that we're seeing the
the fruits of that black women who are
um
are ready to go um and to leave this
country
right if they have the opportunity um
and for me
my sense is that there's no turning back
from that even as there are many
other struggles to be waged before we
say that black women have reached some
sort of political parity in the united
states that just isn't yet true
i would like to add to that um because i
think that what martha said
kind of addresses the candidates who are
being considered
who are definitely well deserving and
qualified probably over qualified
compared to some people um but
i think this is my opinion i think in
addition to the women who
are being considered and rightfully
they should be i think there's a
recognition that black women in this
country
are a political force when it comes to
voting as well
i mean it's been well documented that
doug jones
in on alabama won because
of black women um
being so entrenched and
engaged in the political system that i
think there's a recognition that black
women
are um are voters that need to be
uh satisfied to some extent we they need
to address
our concerns because we vote
we do vote now people want to blame us
for everything you know when stuff
doesn't go
the way they want it to but
statistically we vote
more um and then we vote in certain ways
and so i think the democratic party is
being strategic
and not only recognizing and considering
certain particular individuals who are
qualified but i think they're being
strategic when it comes to
engaging with the black community
knowing that
we um have certain concerns that we want
to have
addressed and we will vote for the
people who will address those concerns
thank you so much for that uh martha can
you
speak to some of the issues that may
keep people from the polls this year or
the efforts that are underway to perhaps
keep people from the polls
i mean we have the whole situation with
the post office we have
um we have voting roles being
um reviewed and names falling off
there's like a whole
series of things that are happening do
you think that's strategic
and what needs to be done to address it
the lessons of the 19th amendment of the
19th amendment
are that indeed lawmakers will use
um rules written on their face
neutrally right nobody says i'm
disenfranchising black people in the
letter of the law nobody says i'm
disenfranchising women but they'll use
their discretion
to apply those laws in way that
disproportionately keep
in our own time people of color
women away from the polls so
here we are in an era of voter
suppression
um exacerbated by
a pandemic it is so reminiscent to me
of the poll taxes of the literacy tests
of the understanding tests
of the grandfather clauses that
characterize the 19th amendment
era the lynching the violence
um today i think is mirrored in
a corona virus that has
disproportionately
um uh visited
and um caused the illness and the death
of both black americans and
latino americans now people have to put
their
take their lives in their hands once
again in 2020
to get to the polls the parallels um are
not only eerie um they should stop us on
our
tracks the last thing i'll say is
because we have no constitutionally
guaranteed
right to vote in this country while the
15th and the 19th amendment and other
amendments
went to to an important degree
limiting the kinds of things that states
could do
the u.s constitution does not guarantee
any of us
the right to vote the burden remains on
us
um to insist to be vigilant to
overcome the hurdles oftentimes at great
risk that was true a hundred years ago
and it looks like that will also be true
in november
i'm someone who's written um about the
need
for a constitutional amendment that
finally guarantees to every american the
right to vote
but we don't live yet in that kind of
political regime
and so we fight at so many turns don't
we
in order simply to cast ballots
another question from the women of
impact group how do you think the tone
of the biden campaign might shift once
he announces his running mate
put another way what does a campaign
need from a vp
pick and i would add if that pick
is a a black woman and this sort of
climate that we're living in
how do we think that impacts the
campaign
i just wanted to add one thing to the
last point before i get into this which
is um
i think the other issue with when it
comes to voting
and potential voting suppression is just
this
still this dynamic that everything is
still run by the states
is considered there being a national
approach because they're too much
there's too much
uh variation among states and in
the type of voting machines that people
use um then the
hours that voting places are open just
all of those type of things are
so there's such a variety and disparity
between states that it's it's just not
consistent and i think that puts certain
states
at more of a disadvantage than others on
when it comes to
a potential vice presidential pick and
how that might impact
the um campaign um
i you know like i said i think that
there has to be i mean we're in the
middle of a
um health crisis
we're in the middle of a financial
crisis and we're in the middle
of a civic engagement uh civil unrest
crisis
i mean there's so many crises that are
going on right now and all of them
disproportionately affect people of
color
um and so whoever ends up being the vice
presidential pick
and joe biden himself has to address
these issues in order to have any kind
of resonance
with real with people's real concerns
and real life really called kitchen
table
um kind of issues you know otherwise
it's it will it will be considered more
of the same
and i don't think that our country will
do well
with more of the same
martin did you want to add anything to
that before we
pivot sure i i guess i would
add that i think um
one thing i'm sure
vice president biden will get if he
nominates an african-american woman
um is someone who comes out of
works through and is committed to
a real humanitarian perspective on the
future
of this country black women have for 200
years
spoken again and again
through the perspective of humanity it
was one of the words i was really
surprised to discover
again and again in my research for
vanguard
and so it would be a mistake to expect
that
black women come to public office
including high office like the vice
presidency
um to
speak somehow to other black women alone
um that the political tradition um out
of which these candidates
come is one that really
looks to yes speak through the
experience of black women it's not one
experience in the united states
to speak through those experiences and
then to speak
to the interests of all of humanity um
and
i can't imagine um a more
timely necessary vital
perspective to bring to american
politics
than one that really um opens arms
um to all of us um takes the measure of
this country
as francis ellen watkins harper put it
um a very long time ago right the
weakest and the feeblest
and that is the measure of this country
and black women have been working
through that ethical and political view
for a long time
i think it can only be an asset not only
to the democratic party
but an asset to the nation as a whole
and so we have a kind of a related
question
um from someone who
asks what if anything in our current
moment gives you
hope how can we continue inspiring the
kind of active participation that will
push us forward
i can tell you i mean maybe martha feels
the same way
because i teach
my students give me hope because they're
right out of high school um so some of
them are voting for the first time ever
and the level of engagement that i see
um and the lack the amount of
knowledge that they have about the
different um
issues they are way more politically
savvy than i think
people give you know the young folks
credit for
um and and so i see another generation
and a next generation becoming engaged
and involved
and so that gives me a sense of hope
that
um you know that the
the work isn't going to stop just
because
we have one generation that is leaving
us and i know it's very sad
obviously to have some of the pioneers
and some of the towering figures on of
our country who have fought for justice
and equality to
be leaving us but i do feel
that there is another generation that
will be equally impactful
in different ways and they give me hope
fantastic martha yes
i'll say that it has been my ballast
in these months these unprecedented
months and all of the challenges
has been my students shout out to them
and
i see them on zoom and not much else
these days but there they are
and that has been really important i
i'll but i'll add that i i do think that
um
you know part of um the way i would tell
the story of african-american women's
political power is
about the story of generations you you
noted
michelle duster as a generational
activist i
i think i don't know how michelle feels
about that moniker but
i do think there's something right to
the ways in which
generations bequeath they lead they
model
and they inspire us and
i am excited to
hang around long enough to see the
generation of
black girls and young black women
who are watching six african-american
women
vie for the vice presidential nomination
how our sense of possibility
our sense of who we are where we belong
what we can do what we must do
um i really believe that we are who
whoever the nominee is
um the names of these women their faces
um their work um are inspiring next
generations to do things that
perhaps we can't even quite yet imagine
um and that gives me a great deal of
hope because what i know is that
while there is tremendous adversity in
front of us um there's never been a
generation of
african-american women certainly who
have sat down or
turned around or given up um that we
have nurtured one another
through hardship and across generations
i'm so i'm excited
for my granddaughters and my
great-granddaughters um as i'm sure ida
wells was
for you michelle in her own way
understanding that that is
the sort of work that we do and that is
the timeline
the tough timeline of the work that we
do um that it
continues out across generations but i
think there's something on the horizon
that is
really exciting
and and speaking of passing the torch
michelle i just have to ask this
question because the women of
impact group is a group of women of
sort of different backgrounds um talk
about the about the
sort of joy and the responsibility or
perhaps even the burden
of being the great granddaughter of ida
b
wells like how have you navigated that
um i think
um there there are you know
pros and cons to everything and i think
one of the challenges
for me is that most people wonder
i mean rightfully so focus on the probes
you know because i get a lot of oh wow
that's so cool you get you
you know your great grandmother was one
of my heroes and that must be so
and so it's just a sort of adolation for
my
grandmother which i appreciate and i'm
happy that people
are so enthusiastic about her
um and they know about a lot about her
and
they appreciate the work that she did
and
so the challenge becomes for me
feeling there there are moments when i
feel invisible
um because i feel that so much is
about her that i'm
i'm i mean people um yeah
so that's one of the challenges and it's
something that i i do
um i'm purposeful about within myself
of being clear
within my own head of who i am
um because it does kind of get lost in
the mix sometimes
um and so i have you know
i challenge myself to sort of define
myself for myself even if other
people don't see it um and i have
even more recently been very purposeful
about
engaging in um activities
that just are for my own
self-fulfillment
to make myself happy that has nothing to
do with being a great granddaughter of
ib wells
because that's just me i mean it's just
maybe it's just me but i just feel a
need
to to be able to have my own
um definition of myself
um and so those are sort of the
struggle i mean of course i'm you know
honored and feel very fortunate that i
am related to somebody
who um was so amazing
and does still inspire people so much
because you know my brothers and i tease
each other like we could be related to
you know mass murderer or something like
we'd have that as a you know legacy
we'd have to overcome so if given a
choice you know you want to have a
positive
um but it it carving out my own identity
i would say it's the biggest sort of
challenge
particularly since so much of your work
is about carrying on the legacy
so do you feel like they often get
blurred
externally even as you're working within
yourself to try to create those
lines um
i feel that i have had to
um be purposeful about making
sure that people say my actual name
um and recognize my my michelle
actuals um credentials because my
title is not great granddaughter of ida
b wallace i mean i am a professor
i am a writer i have done a lot of other
things and so
you know just within a professional
space
i i i have to ask for that
and so that just kind of
makes me realize that it's not top of
mind for other people
but i have to advocate for myself um
and so it maybe it's just a little
more of a hurdle than it is for some
other people who
automatically are called professor or
automatically or called historian or
whatever
and i'm called great granddaughter i'm
like but that's my relation to her
that's not my title
right so it's just kind of an
interesting dynamic
and then martha i think we um have time
for
this question for you so much has
happened during the past year
um but your book was already underway so
if you were adding another chapter and i
don't know maybe you have a lot of what
we've been living through
included in the book but if you had
another chapter to
had that included 2020 particularly
these past
six months what would you write
well the first thing i i want to confess
if i could is
is what an inspiration michelle duster
is to me and if you wonder whether
that's
true i hope you'll read the introduction
to vanguard where
for the very first time i try and write
about my own grandmother and
great-grandmother and
great-great-grandmother
and their struggles for voting rights um
uh for me this is um
this was important for me to try and
um find the right voice the right tone
the right
place from which to write out of family
and then write
a bigger history but one of the things i
think i would have underscored frankly
is that
if i'd known so many of us were going to
be home
all bound up together with loved ones
for
a long long periods of time and
many of us in very small spaces i would
have urged
more directly more of us frankly to
think about family history
as a beginning place for thinking about
the history of
women's politics and women's voting
rights that
um i was shy to do that michelle has
been bold
but i do think that i discovered that i
knew too little about the women in my
family
and i think today i would suggest
everybody's
spurring project summer project fall
project winter project
should be to intro you know interview
the elders um in your midst because it
turns out
that in many many many american families
if not all american families um women
have stories
about their voting rights about their
first votes
um and they are meaningful and and ones
that we should
collect and hold on to and preserve
because we're not done as this pandemic
has demonstrated with the struggles over
voting rights
in the united states as shelby versus
holder has made plain
and i think capturing our family stories
is a
is something that i've just dabbled in a
bit
at the beginning of the book um but it's
something i'm coming back to more and
more because i realize
um that that is part of what fuels and
informs
who we are as women in politics today so
if you don't know your mother's story
your grandmother's story your
great-grandmother's story
um i think it's time to find out
okay so that is our call to action for
today i just want to thank you both uh
for giving us an
hour of your time this has been a really
inspiring and insightful conversation
and i am looking forward to the book i'm
also looking forward to
exploring more of the work that you're
doing michelle and seeing
how i can be helpful thank you so much
have a good afternoon
thank you
i